يعد خط انابيب الدروجبا احد اكبر شبكات
انابيب النفط الخام في العالم وهو ينقل
النفط الروسيه الى اوروبا وقد دخل مرحله
التشغيل عام
1964 يمتد طول الشبكه نحو خمسه الاف
وخمسمائه كيلومتر وهي تبدا من مدينه في
روسيا حيث تلتقي الانابيب التي تحمل النفط
الخام من سيبيريا والاورال وبحر قزوين
يتجه بعدها الخط الى موزير في بيلاروسيا
حيث يتوزع على فرعين شمالي وجنوبي يمر
الشمالي عبر بيلاروسيا الى بولندا
والمانيا بينما يمر الفرع الجنوبي عبر
اوكرانيا ليصل الى السوفاكيا
وتشيكوانغاريا تتراوح الكميه التي يمكن ان
تنقلها شبكه دروجبا بين مليون و 200 الف
برميل ومليون واربعمائه الف برميل يوميا
مع امكانيه زياده ذلك لتصل الكميه الى
مليوني برميل يوميا